Ewww, what is it?
Just a little piece of brain
You always said you were looking for a guy with brains
** Hard rock music playing **
Her blood was surging through me
** Growling **
Soup sandwich
Should've taken the elevator down
** Screaming **
Oh god!
He got stuck with the nozzle on, air's blowing in his body,
his body's poppin of his muscles
That is disgusting
** Car horn **
** Tire explosion **
** Slice **
** Bowling balls roll out **
Oh my god!
** Screaming **
Oh god
Someone outsourced their healthcare to the wrong provider
** Rummaging **
** Screaming **
Tripper, come on buddy, dinner
ughhh, what is it this time a rabbit or a possum?
I heard you got some head
** Squish **
That doesn't sound good
Think I just became evidence
** Squishing **
I'm gonna be sick again
** Rat squeaking **
Whoa
I think she just ratted herself out
** Hard rock music playing **